hi my name is jaku and i'm director of
product management at tungle and today
i'm going to give you a short tutorial
on the
fungal blackberry beta
so you've received a link to download
the the dongle app and once you've
installed it you'll have a toggle icon
on your home view
so to launch the app you just click on
the icon and it's going to bring you to
a cyan prompt
if you're an existing tungle user you'll
be able to enter the same credentials
here if you don't
already have an account just click on
the register
fill out the form and you'll be able to
get an account free account so
for now we'll just
sign in here
that's going to log me in with the same
credentials as a regular tango dot me
website
the first time you launch the app you'll
see a tutorial um for now we'll skip it
but please
go through it and send us feedback
whether it's meaningful uh too long
definitely not too short
and how it could be improved if needs be
so for now i'm going to skip it
first time also you're going to be asked
if you want to sync so you pick whether
you want to sync contacts and the
calendars you want to sync with us
and once you click on sync now it's
going to uh upload those contacts and
calendar to uh dongle
may take a few minutes if you have a few
thousands contact and calendar events
otherwise it should be done in a matter
of let's say 30 seconds or so
so in my case it's almost
done
and
so
now i'm ready my contacts have been
synced with tungle as well as my
blackberry calendars
so you're brought to what we call the
home view so here
on the top section
and once it's uh it's downloaded from
toggle you'll see your uh meetings for
the day
so the first time you run the app it
needs to download them
uh later it will cache them
when you click on the top section it
will also show you uh your dongle
meetings
so these meetings are actually uh taken
from my blackberry calendars where i
uploaded to dongle and now i'm
retrieving them if my tunnel accounts
will sync with my outlook or from my
form or my mac for instance those events
will also be displayed here
okay
the contacts
section is used to
show your
your colleagues calendar so
again the first time you launch the app
it will retrieve your calendars uh it
may take a few minutes a few seconds the
first time
but let's see
in this case
so now it's updating the busy status
you'll see once they they appear that
those that are green means they're
currently available according to their
calendar those that are
are red are currently busy so let's see
uh calendar of sharing buddy nicholas
for instance he will retrieve
his
calendar
so it's coming
by the way you can share previously only
or meeting details so when you share
meeting details you have the the subject
of these meetings
so uh by the way you can share uh across
platforms uh so blackberry to outlook to
mac without problem to google the same
thing
so now let's go through uh the schedule
meetings
so
to use this uh this feature you click on
schedule meeting it will show you a
residential
view of your calendar
so to pick participants you go here
use a search
and if this person happens to be a
tunnel sharing contact you'll also see
their availability
the proposed time you just click
on the cell
let's propose a bunch of times and
remember uh the more time you propose a
better chance the meeting gets booked
and also if you're synced
whatever times that you've proposed if
your calendar change your availability
will be automatically updated so no
chance of double booking
if you want you can change the view
with filters by default it's working
hours and if you're too lazy to propose
time you can also use the dongle suggest
basically it will create a server for
available times for the participants so
once you're done you click on next
you enter the subject location message
you send it and it's going to send
emails to all the participants
so let's cancel it for now
uh from the management uh section you'll
be able to see all of your
dongle pending meetings as well as the
upcoming book meetings
and finally in the action section action
item section you'll see a sharing
request that you've received
where we can access
or decline from here
last tab is the options
this is where you control what calendars
or contacts to be sync
also the frequency so by default the
calendar will calendar and contacts will
be synced both ways to width on goal
every 10 minutes
you can force the syncing from here and
if you're having network problems you
can also change to a different network
from here
so uh last thing but probably the
coolest we also integrated with your
email so let's say you have an email and
you want to schedule a meeting with this
email to to discuss the subject of it so
what you do you just left click
schedule with tango it's going to launch
the app and
automatically fill the list of
participants with those that are in the
2 and cc of the email
so bear with me a second here
yeah it's taking a bit of time
okay
so as you can see frederick was the uh
one of the participants and uh if he was
a tumble user i will also see his
availability here if you share it with
me
so the same thing is available also from
the uh your address book
so basically uh that's it that's the uh
short tutorial of tango
let us know
if you have any problems feedback
suggestions
and i will be glad to help you thanks
bye
you